l'enquète people l enquête people c'est
sur les [ __ ] puisque c'est le gros
événement le week-end dernier à bordeaux
les [ __ ] ont lancé leur tournée 2010
9 vous savez qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de polémiques
c'est un événement qui est très très
attendu et la présence de deux champions
du monde aussi vont ils réussir à
remonter la pente les audiences soient
un petit peu diminué et puis même
l'image c'est un peu abîmée regardez et
ensuite on a parlé après avec un
journaliste qui est avec était avant
coulisses six dates à bordeaux et plus
de 60000 spectateurs voilà donc à quoi
ressemble la tournée des [ __ ]
version 2019
grosse ambiance
[Musique]
sur scène 50 stars les historiques comme
patrick fiori mimie mathy zazie michael
jones et les petits nouveaux qui lie en
amap et et slimane
objectif fêter les 30 ans des [ __ ]
un anniversaire placé sous le signe d'un
nouvel hymne aux signes et vianney
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un énorme coup de communication avec
l'art formation des inconnus qui
reprennent leurs chansons mythiques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et dommage émouvant
car cette année les [ __ ] les restos
du coeur ont perdu celle qui leur avait
consacré sa vie véronique colucci la
femme de coluche est décédé en avril
dernier
depuis trois ans la troupe n'a plus non
plus de patrons musicale jean jacques
goldman l'ayant quittée après 30 ans de
bons et loyaux services
cette année donc tout le monde met la
main à la pâte et une chose est sûre les
[ __ ] ne lâche rien beaucoup de
jolies sono comme ici patrick bruel
[Musique]
- de sketches donc et plus de musique
et si après une année de doute les
[ __ ] avaient retrouvé la recette
gagnante encore éventuelle remontée la
porte bien à shanghai que vous passera
dans un instant mais on avec quick look
ce qui est journaliste à télé câble sat
hebdo et vous étiez donc dans les
coulisses soyez bienvenue alors c'était
quoi l'ambiance des âneries qu'une assez
bonne assez bonne bonne ambiance
alors c'est vrai que nous après le
spectacle qui dure quatre heures ennemi
commun est sur place on nous invite au
catherine la cantine avec tous les
artistes qui se croisent parfois être ce
pas parce qu'on ne se parle pas mais ont
confirmé qu'ils s'aiment pas beaucoup
en tout cas on nous a dit que voilà
comme dans toute expérience humaine
toute aventure humaine parfois qui
s'entend pas très bien les yeux non
honnêtement je n'en sais rien a appris
lundi a pris le lead cette année puisque
l'on n'est qu'à pas de leaders
véritablement parler d'art globice peau
et de michaël youn
or les deux ne sont pas ne sont pas
venus voilà alors c'est bien dommage
parce que michaël youn moi je trouve à
injecter du sang neuf et beaucoup
d'énergie c'était impressionnant de le
voir ces dernières années sur scène
malheureusement elle n'est pas là cette
année je pense que patrick bruel est
vraiment le pilier ou des produits
légaux et dès que j'ai besoin de ton
avis je t'aime que tu envoies un texto
et je n'ai pas ton numéro donc voila et
kaki et c'était michaël youn qui
écrivaient les les sketchs la plupart
des skates sensations lui en parler
maintenant
alors là il ya la bande à fifi qui
revient donc ouais il ya six nouveaux
dons
alors on a dit qu'il y avait moins de
sketches mais a quand même beaucoup
d'humour il ya isabelle nanty harry ary
abittan douay
qu'est ce qu'on a fait au bon dieu il y
avait un vrai de vrai vous qui les avez
tous vu quasiment est ce que cette année
le show est mieux que l'année dernière
où un peu moins bien il est très alors
ils ont voulu faire cette année c'est ce
qu'on nous a dit et ils ont voulu faire
quelque chose de moins de moins
carnavalesque on va dire un de plus
léché plus précis plus professionnel
dans l'émotion musicale met donc c'est
bien
voilà merci bien c'est ce qu'ont paléo
est ce que je suis et je vais vous dire
la vérité merci ça a duré quatre heures
et demie ouais ya des changements de
décor ouais et pendant les champions des
corps on a des lives contre la corde
qu'on ne verra pas sur tf1 bien sûr et
c'était très long et c'était tellement
précis la réalisation on voit que c'est
fait pour la télévision
d'accord plus tellement un show bon pour
les gens moi je me suis un petit peu
ennuyé à un moment donné mais le sable à
la télé à la télé ça sera magnifique
parce que sur les trois spectacles qui
sont captés en fait ce qu'on verra la
télévision c'était un centre de best-of
mais voilà quoi d'accord toujours et
donc c'est un peu déceptif quand on y va
parce qu'on verra par exemple moi je
n'ai pas vu les actions goldman est là
ou pas c'était la grande rumeur non il
ne reviendra plus et un mini à chaque
fois leur demande mais alors est-ce que
jean-jacques non c'est fini l'ipad
apparition sur un écran si au début pour
rendre une leçon il ya un corps mais
déjà on sait que ça va durer quatre
heures sans nom mais il ya des petits
sms de temps en temps qui sont envoyées
à des [ __ ] pour voir on sait qu'on
leur donne en exemple la phrase obispo
qui dit je suis sortie du jeu parce que
je suis en tournée bon déjà c'est un
côté presque à prendre du pognon qu'à
leur année j'ai aussi le sentiment qui
est des choses à changer au resto et
sainte éléphant mâle routine et d'usure
notamment dans la façon de le faire mais
encore une fois est-ce qu'ils le font
pour s'amuser ou est-ce qu'ils le font
pour eux mathieu ça c'est ridicule
que ce soit bien ou pas on s'en fout
l'intérêt des restos du coeur c'est de
faire de l'audience avant sa passe wales
ou vendu 10 pour apporter de l'argent
restos du coeur maintenant la qualité du
spectacle c'est anecdotique quelques cas
un but c'est que ça marche c'est tout et
ça marche
il ya eu une baisse légère mais comme il
ya une baisse de toutes les audiences
depuis des années mais sa marque va
quand même si ça marche et que les gens
se sont bien on va acheter le disque
mais sa frappe
un choc quand il y avait des dd diot par
exemple céline dion maurane
c'était magnifique ça donnait envie
d'acheter moi pardon mais quand je sais
mimie mathy qui chantent ils achètent
vraiment pour les restos mais j'ai pas
la voiture mais l organe à toutes mes
chances j'en achète quand même parce que
c'est une bonne oeuvre s'ils perdent là
mais quand c'est mieux c'est mieux ah
oui voilà le monde d'accord et la nature
on nous a dit qu'aujourd'hui certains
acheter le disque ne l'écoutait même pas
oui parce que c'était pour faire plaisir
parce qu'elle est très beau donner
pardon parce qu'elle est très beau duo
adoré ce qu'ont bien journalistes qui ne
dormaient pas à ma nation des inconnus
et franchement les revoir tous les trois
chanter c'est tes meilleurs tubes c'est
génial en plus c'est le meilleur
événement ça de ce qui s'est passé
non mais après les journées des autres
la chanson en hommage ils ont chanté ça
les gens pleurer puis les bons moments
chantés pauvres ni kulchy les gens
pleuraient
parce que d y avait de la glace qui
était avec beaucoup d'émotion on parle
de sujets parce qu'il a été mis teeq ça
que maurane céline dion
c'était magnifique est ce qu'il ya un
duo magnifique quelque chose de hockey
est pas une grande ici c'est très léchée
c'était
vous êtes invités on sait que c'est très
compliqué de se faire inviter aux restos
du coeur on atterrissait à compliquer
dans le désert le concert est ce que
vous dites ça parce que vous êtes
invités vous ne pouvez pas dire ce que
vous pensez vraiment parce qu'on a un
petit peu de mal à vous tous souvient
que la presse magazine people n'est pas
c'est un petit peu que c'est un peu
compliqué pour eux il n'y a pas de
leaders n'y a pas une c'est parce que
vous pouvez dire c'est raté et acheter
de façon on va l'acheter si vous voulez
ce que nous on voit pendant quatre
heures et demie mais parce que les
téléspectateurs
enfin voilà donc on peut pas juger vrai
bien sûr voyez comme si nous monter
cette émission et que tu vois là on
enlevait les interventions de magali
berda bien sûr la bride à l'émission
très différentes mais pas de tir en vue
non plus non mais enfin oui oui
après on peut monter une émission en
phase 6 les roches sont pas bon port
mais alors quoi j où les risques sont
très réussis voilà moi je les sketchs
ont réussi les choses c'est toutes les
critiques qui ont été faites ces
dernières années c'est sur le fait que
ça soit trop carnage oui bah justement
ils sont mais en fait j'ai commencé à le
faire dès lundi des sketches aussi y en
a très peu cette année on peut acheter
les vitres ou daniela est quelque chose
de beaucoup plus grave que la qualité du
spectacle c'est qu'en plein gilet jaune
il ya beaucoup de gens qui reprochent
aux [ __ ] de n'avoir rien dit un
silence à 3,10 à souder notamment les
échelons en plus il ya eu quand même une
phrase ces millionnaires qui demande aux
pauvres de donner de l'argent et ce à
l'image des [ __ ] elle peut être
écornée par sa beaucoup plus que par la
qualité bien sûr que les bien sûr droit
d'auteur ça reste quelque temps les
artistes sur la grille ils ne sont pas
payés c'est quand même regarder laisse
un message non mais c'est formidable
moi je dis jusqu'à temps ça chauffe dans
le dos on ne doit pas critiquer les
enfants non mais vraiment même même en
tant que journaliste on peut d'ailleurs
vous avez fait une très belle prestation
[Rires]
dany avec nous l'enfoiré vont-ils
réussir à remonter la pente non à 52,2
mais encore une fois je pensais que le
leader effectivement naturel c'était
patrick bruel je suis ravi qu'il soit un
petit peu déçu parce que je n'y sois pas
mais c'est vrai que florent peine une
année où il y avait j'aimerais que
bienne et ya ici nous écoute et leur
apathie blacks à une année où il y avait
six lignes lyon où il y avait ça serait
bien que des grands grands ndar se
remobilise pour y aller et que ce soit
bien de donner la statue de johnny
hallyday était peut-être envie de
regarder on sera tous devant évidemment
c'est un événement absolument c'est un
événement